Hola en gustos saludarlos soy Raúl
blanco y en esta oportunidad vamos a
analizar los acontecimientos más
destacados que tuvieron lugar esta
semana en el mundo Sean bienvenidos a
una semana en el mundo los acompaño en
reemplazo de mi compañero Santiago López
González para conversar sobre estos
temas vamos a saludar a Jesús mesa eres
periodista de asuntos internacionales
Jesús un gusto tenerlo con nosotros en
nuestro programa bienvenido
Hola Muchas gracias por la invitación y
muy contento de estar acá también
tenemos a Carlos chica periodista de
asuntos internacionales y director del
podcast el mundo en rayos x de la Radio
Nacional de Colombia Carlos Gracias por
estar con nosotros en una semana en el
mundo un gusto de estar hoy con ustedes
y con la audiencia y también tenemos a
Stefano Pot sebón en ese periodista
internacional en medios como 100 en y la
bbc entre otros o medios también
internacionales Gracias por estar con
nosotros también Stefano un placer bueno
acompáñanos con sus opiniones
comentarios y preguntas en nuestras
redes sociales France 24 raya al piso es
y nuestra etiqueta numeral una semana en
el mundo f24 ahora sí vamos a entrar en
materia para hablar de la situación
actual de inestabilidad política en el
Reino Unido tras la renuncia de la
primera ministra británica lize lo que
abre el camino para la elección de un
nuevo Primer Ministro británico que
podría llevar a Boris Johnson nuevamente
al 10 de Down Street o su ex ministro de
economía Ruiz también a penny Morgan
exministra de defensa pero veamos el
momento exacto cuando Liz Ross anunció
su división
hablé con Su Majestad del Rey para
notificarle que dimito como líder del
partido conservador esta mañana Me
encontré con el presidente del comité
1922 decidimos que habrá una elección
que se completará durante la siguiente
semana eso asegurará que nos mantenemos
en el camino de cumplir con nuestros
planes Fiscales de mantener la
estabilidad económica y la seguridad de
nuestro país seguiré como primera
ministra hasta que se haya elegido un
sucesor
empecemos entonces con nuestro análisis
y quiero comenzar con Jesús Jesús que
viene para Reino Unido porque tanta
inestabilidad política en este momento
bueno Raúl yo creo que esto es
consecuencia de un proceso que Comenzó
desde el brexit en 2016 en el que en
cierto modo los conservadores no tenían
un plan claro desde que ganaron la
elección Pues a favor del brexit y pues
hemos visto que desde ese momento han
tenido ya con esta tres primeras
ministras un montón de inestabilidad
dentro de las filas Entonces yo creo que
esto es consecuencia precisamente de esa
falta de plan que tenían los
conservadores en el momento que ganaron
el brexit que como pues estudiado y se
ha hablado mucho pues se hizo Gracias
también a una campaña pues de
desinformación muy fuerte que al final
pues hoy tiene esa consecuencia de esta
inestabilidad Carlos estás de acuerdo
con lo que dice Jesús que también
concuerda digamos de alguna manera con
analistas internacionales que hemos
tenido en Francia 24 que dicen que sí
que es cierto que el partido conservar
británico viene en declive digamos o en
crisis desde que anunció su salida de la
Unión Europea y por supuesto tras el
brexit sin duda porque Fíjate lo que
pasa después de la renuncia de la señora
sus propios compartidarios por lo menos
12 de ellos que tienen asiento en el
parlamento habían ya salido a pedir que
renunciara Y ella dice en esas
declaración que acabamos de escuchar
Ella dice yo tiro la toalla porque no
pude cumplir el mandato que me comentó
el partido mandato que supuestamente era
generar unas condiciones muy
neoliberales para reactivar la economía
poner el crecimiento del Reino Unido por
encima de todo no importa si la gente
rica se hace más rica y los pobres se
hacen más pobres y ahora le están
cobrando eso se lo están cobrando a ella
con un gesto de bastante insolidaridad
que de todas maneras lo tiene que llevar
a uno como Ciudadano normal A
preguntarse qué ha hecho el partido
conservadora durante estos dos años para
que una señora que acaba de asumir el
cargo de gobernante haga lo que hizo e
improvise Aparentemente de la manera en
que lo hizo aunque he leído varios
análisis que dicen que ella estaba
recibiendo la presión de los sectores
más ultraconservadores de su propio
partido para aplicar estas medidas que
sin dudas unas medidas de corte de
estirpe de oliveral pero pura pura pura
Stefano su opinión además curioso porque
precisamente 44 días en el carro los
mismos conservadores la botaron a ella y
los mismos conservadores pidieron su
cabeza entonces que realmente quiere el
partido conservador y quien realmente
puede un líder para sustituir Alice para
llevar a cabo a Reino Unido un poco a
flote no en toda esta inestabilidad
política lo hacías también eh Carlos en
un momento crisis de la inflación crisis
de la energía producto de la guerra en
Ucrania que eso ese tema ya vamos a
hablar más adelante pero pero digamos
para sortear todos estos problemas que
tiene Reino Unido como como toda Europa
Sí yo creo que la crisis de Reino Unido
obviamente es más más profunda de resto
de Europa y y la renuncia del ISSSTE lo
lo demuestra antes de concordando con
los otros huésped obviamente brexit
llega una juega una parte importante
hubo una columna del Garden de Jonathan
freeland esta semana donde muy
lúcidamente conectaba lo que pasó en
2016 con lo que pasó ahorita y se la
recomiendo Pero también yo creo que
Reino Unido y a Inglaterra en particular
están viviendo un momento de reconning
de reconocimiento de auto investigación
autoanálisis histórico y es interesante
que esto pase aunque a veces la historia
es la la
pasen el mismo a menos de un mes de la
muerte de la reina histórica Isabel la
segunda es un momento donde el brexit
nace de una crisis de identidad
particularmente de Inglaterra porque
hemos visto que en país de gales en
Wells en Escocia y en Irlanda del Norte
ganaron ganado el remain ganaron
mantenerse en una identidad europea lo
que votaron para salir de la Unión
Europea fueron los ingleses que aún
viven un enorme
síntoma de cuál es nuestro rol en el
mundo la pérdida del poder la pérdida de
las colonias y listo salió ganadora por
exactamente por la parte por la ala más
dura del conservatorismo inglés por los
miembros del partido que no son el
público grande de Inglaterra fue elegida
como Primer Ministro pero votada por
menos del 1% de la población inglesa que
son los miembros históricos del partido
conservador británico donde más lampante
más evidente esta crisis de
reconocimiento una crisis que yo creó
vamos a dividir en Europa por los
próximos cinco diez años hemos visto que
ya Escocia está hablando de un segundo
referéndum ya tiene fecha ya la Irlanda
del Norte ganó un partido a favor de la
unificación de toda la isla irlandesa o
esta pulsiones no hay en el país de
gales todavía pero evidente que es una
nación hija del imperio británico hija
de lo que fue Inglaterra en el siglo 17
18 19 y Siglo XX Y que ahora llega un
momento histórico de cuál es nuestro rol
en el mundo y la la crisis de ahora fue
tan breve tan tan rápida que
probablemente en leyendo los libros de
historias en 50 años no nos recordaremos
del issstras nos recordaremos si de el
momento en que Inglaterra se empieza a
cuestionar cuál es su rol en la
comunidad internacional y en el mundo
hablando de la comunidad internacional
hablemos de la Unión Europea también es
Jesús porque como que Inglaterra en todo
esto frente a sus aliados europeos
frente al bloque comunitario
Bueno yo creo que Inglaterra como como
comentaba acá mi colega está en un
momento pues de reconocerse y al mismo
tiempo en una situación muy difícil con
todo el tema de la guerra en Ucrania y
yo creo que De cierto modo este este
episodio que que ocurrió en el mundo
mostró Las verdaderas consecuencias de
aislarse de del bloque realmente digamos
que
la guerra en Ucrania termina de alguna
forma generando una crisis a nivel pues
territorial en Europa estamos viendo que
hay mucha preocupación con el invierno o
mucha preocupación con la con el tema
energético y esto de alguna forma es
reflejo de ese aislamiento que de alguna
forma con el brexit de ellos buscaron
hacer y ahora pues están viendo pues esa
consecuencia de precisamente nosotros
queremos solucionar las cosas solos pero
nos dimos cuenta que éramos pues mucho
más fuerte juntos de lo que estamos
haciendo ahora entonces creo que por ahí
está el problema hoy en en Inglaterra y
pues en Reino Unido hay voces en en
Escocia por ejemplo como comentaban de
que quieren volver a hacer un referendo
y Pues digamos que estas voces están más
fuertes desde el brexit de 2016 porque
pues si recordamos el último referendo
se hizo antes de la de la de la votación
y pues la mayoría de Escocia votó que se
querían quedar entonces pues hay una
inestabilidad local que sumada pues a
toda esta crisis global pues genera esta
crisis que de alguna forma terminó con
la renuncia de la primera ministra
también Carlos ha sonado la idea de una
selecciones generales pues bastante
improbables viéndolo de primera mano
porque todo el partido conservador
tendría que votar en contra del gobierno
todos los parlamentarios encontrar el
gobierno para pues qué sucede que ser un
suicidio digamos para el propio partido
no pero pero digamos que sería una de
las salidas o sería la única salida que
tendría ahora Reino Unido el gobierno
británico para salir de esta crisis o
qué otra posibilidad tiene digamos real
para alejarse esta inestabilidad yo
creería que una selecciones generales
anticipadas sería lo mejor porque podría
medir el pulso político real de poder
hoy en el Reino Unido pero a mí me
preocupa mucho que incluso el
cubrimiento mediático se ha centrado en
la reacción de los mercados en la
reacción de las bolsas en el fenómeno
inflacionario en la caída estruendosa de
la libra que regresa a unos niveles muy
inquietantes para cualquier economía y
que de esta discusión yo no sé si en el
Reino Unido se esté dando estén ausentes
los ciudadanos de a pie tenga ausentes
los movimientos sociales los sindicatos
las organizaciones feministas los
ambientalistas la gente que está
preocupada para que no vaya a aumentar
la pobreza para que este impacto de la
crisis climática y de la crisis
energética que se aproxima para este
invierno no vaya a sufrir de una manera
desmedida en proporción a otros sectores
de la población
mantener esta discusión en el parlamento
y en el escenario electoral y Solamente
pensando en el curso que pueda tener el
producto interno bruto que parece lo que
es lo único que le preocupa este sector
más conservador olvidándose de la gente
y de estas dinámicas sociales en un
mundo globalizado de esas agendas hoy
importantes Me parece que eso puede
generar una crisis de confianza en el
sistema democrático mismo y acabar de
desvertebrar completamente la función
que puedan llegar a tener los partidos
políticos y el parlamento como unos
mecanismos de conexión de la sociedad
con las decisiones que se toman en un
estado moderno
Carlos es que sin duda alguna esta
discusión no se ha tenido porque están
precisamente el partido conservador
viendo cómo arreglarse ellos para
mantenerse en el poder y como lo dices
tú es cierto la ciudadanía británica
está quedando de lado en lo que tendría
que ser la prioridad no para un gobierno
lo hablamos precisamente también el día
de ayer con nuestra corresponsal cuando
cuando renunció en un poco de nuestra
análisis que hicimos en nuestro programa
en la mañana pero Stefano para ti Cómo
pudiera ser el Reino Unido realmente
esta inestabilidad política apartando un
poco las elecciones generales que pues
no están a la vuelta de la esquina
sí evidente que esta conversación que
que Reino Unido está teniendo consigo
misma va a tener tiempo no es un
problema que se pueda resolver con una
vaya elección con una elección de
emergencia aunque esto es lo que
probablemente necesita el país en este
momento para volver a encontrar un poco
de fuerza
yo me fijé mucho en el día de hoy en las
ópticas porque cuando cayó el gobierno
de
del ISSSTE hay otro gobierno que se está
instalando en Europa que es el italiano
Que obviamente claro conozco bien por
por mi nacionalidad y hoy el presidente
Mario draghi saliendo decidió dejar su
última rueda de prensa con los
periodistas en Bruselas no lo hizo en
Roma para despedirse del público lo hizo
en Bruselas le preguntaron Cómo la
guerra en Ucrania impactó a Europa y él
dice Europa Europa Ucrania nos hizo
entender que somos más fuertes Unidos
somos más fuerte y me más interesante
que en cambio la lección que sale de lo
que pasó en en Reino Unido en Inglaterra
es que ningún país es una isla ya en una
economía tan globalizada en unos
movimientos políticos tan globalizado
esa pulsión que ganó en 2016 de Take
Back Controls de regañar su soberanía
política porque consideraban que que
Bruselas y la Unión Europea fuera una
invasión de su soberanía
se ha convertido en un en un espejo para
saber en una cosa vagua porque seis años
después la Unión Europea se declara más
fuerte frente a la guerra en Ucrania y
en una
nueva Paul de ugot de esta mañana el 52%
de los ciudadanos británicos consideran
que brexit fue un error claro Entonces
es eso parte de la conversación y
obviamente volver a recorre ese error va
a tener tiempo seguramente A lo mejor
prácticamente imposible en un corto
plazo Carlos rápidamente ya para
terminar estamos hablando de El regreso
posible de Boris Johnson
Street Richard zona que también que se
peleó esta este puesto de Primer
Ministro con listros y Penny Morgan
podrían estar entre ellos tres el nuevo
Primer Ministro pues en estos escenarios
de la política todo es posible así como
fue posible
la reelección de tantos gobernantes que
han sido nefastos en la historia de
muchas democracias que se consideran
modernas cualquier cosa puede pasar
yo no sé cómo es la cultura
británica la cultura de la sociedad
británica pero no sé si allá pueda
llegar a funcionar aquello de
es mejor malo conocido que bueno por
conocer
finalmente Boris Johnson con todo lo que
hizo y con su estereotipo y con su
Estilo de Liderazgo ya demostró de que
es capaz y de que no es capaz de pronto
en estos momentos de crisis apelar a lo
conocido de pronto puede ser un buen
elemento de una campaña por ejemplo para
arrastrar electores incluso algunos
selectores que no hayan votado por él en
las pasadas en las pasadas elecciones o
en los procesos políticos anteriores
cualquier cosa es posible
aquí Habría que ver es la capacidad y la
madurez que tengan los dirigentes
políticos de del Reino Unido hoy de
antemponer los intereses del país a los
intereses partidistas Porque si en una
situación tan crítica económica como la
que está viviendo el país esta crisis
energética que se avecina las
consecuencias que tiene la Guerra de
Ucrania si ellos se ponen en una disputa
electoral y política como si
estuviéramos en un estado de normalidad
eso le puede salir muy costoso al Reino
Unido creo yo y bueno Y también Carlos
agregar que pues recordemos también que
origen son salió principalmente por sus
escándalos personales por el party Gate
y no por sus políticas de estado no pero
bueno cambiamos de tema porque se nos
está acabando el tiempo otra de los
temas principales de esta semana sin
duda diría yo protagonista en ese día
internacional desde el inicio de la
invasión en el mes de febrero es Ucrania
porque esta semana pasaron varias cosas
importantes primero la entrada en vigor
de la ley Marcial en los territorios
adicionados ilegalmente por Rusia que
les otorga facultades especiales a los
gobernadores prorrusos en las regiones
de danés lugans gerson y saporiya además
de la evacuación de civiles de la región
punto estratégico para las tropas del
kremlin que aseguran que Ucrania planea
una contraofensiva mortal y como si
fuera poco los ataques de la
infraestructura civil por parte de Rusia
con drones de fabricación iraní que
Teherán niega que haya entregado en
Moscú para ser usado en en esta guerra
comienzo con Stefano Stefano la
situación actual de gerson no vamos a
enfocarnos en esta región porque están
importante para los rusos porque están
evacuando los civiles porque están
acusando que Ucrania quiere hacer esta
contra ofensiva mortal Incluso el
presidente dijo que querían volar una
Represa para inundar y que ellos no
volvían con la contra ofensiva
evidentemente es difícil en una guerra
No aquí en creerle evidentemente cada
quien va a jalar a su lado pero pero
tratemos a acercarnos a la verdad a la
realidad que está pasando con Jesús Pues
yo creo que lo que está pasando es en
este momento una fase de pausa hemos
visto desde que la guerra comenzó con la
invasión rusa en en febrero y marzo
Rusia tuvo el momento un tubo la
iniciativa hasta más o menos Julio
agosto cuando Ucrania lanzó una grande
contra contra ofensiva que logró
resultados importantes y que culminó yo
creo con la la destrucción del puente
del ataque al puente de de
criminal puente de crimea y con la
conquista de una ciudad clave llamada el
imán que es una un nudo de ferrovía de
ferrocarriles y ahora los dos
contundentes están estudiando el peso y
están estudiando cómo va a ser la
evolución de este conflicto en los
próximos meses Claro que tenemos dosis
fechas importantes en el Horizonte la
primera está del otro lado del mundo son
las elecciones en Estados Unidos y con
la potencialidad que un congreso a
mayoría republicana limite los fondos
que Estados Unidos pase a Ucrania para
para poderse defender y con el rol que
jugaba jugará el invierno y la cuestión
energética en Europa entonces creo que
lo que estamos viendo en gersor son los
dos contundentes tratando de entender
cómo Va qué va a pasar y bueno gerson es
clave porque el prete que Putin utilizó
para para poder comenzar esta iniciativa
que él llamó una operación especial es
defender la la lo rusófonos de esa
región Y entonces Claro que que si
pierde control también de esa región
todo todo la razón por la cual por la
cual fue iniciada fue empezada esta
guerra no no tiene No tiene que existir
Carlos hablemos desde la parte
energética de esta guerra punto clave
ahora de los ataques de Rusia que está
atacando a la infraestructura energética
eléctrica de Ucrania de cara
evidentemente al invierno que van a
estar afectados sin duda alguna y sobre
todo los civiles como ves está
estrategia por parte del kremlin pues es
absolutamente perversa porque obviamente
los civiles según el derecho
internacional el derecho de la guerra
deben tener una protección especial y
atacar blancos civiles como lo ha estado
haciendo especialmente Rusia es un es un
hecho muy lamentable muy deplorable
porque finalmente está utilizando la
población como un mecanismo de presión
un mecanismo de presión ante su propio
gobierno porque en algún momento dado si
la población civil siente que el estado
ucraniano no es capaz de protegerla esas
cosas en un momento dado se le pueden
voltear al gobierno de Ucrania porque
eso usted no me está defendiendo paremos
esta guerra eso puede ser muy peligroso
en términos de la confianza que puede
haber ganado selenski que Aparentemente
Ha logrado consolidar un prestigio y un
liderazgo como militar en la conducción
política de esa guerra Eso me parece muy
peligroso y es muy triste Además porque
está demostrando a estas alturas del
conflicto que la hipótesis de que el
escalamiento militar va a tener flujos
altibajos y que se va a prolongar
durante mucho tiempo es una hipótesis
que empieza a cobrar sentido porque se
empiezan a desmoronar además hipótesis
como las que estoy mencionada sobre
animales Putin justifica inicialmente
Esa llamada operación especial en
Ucrania el otro día hablando con el
profesor rubinsky Vladimir rubinsky que
es muy frecuentemente consultado por
ustedes aquí Él recordaba algo que es
muy importante en la región del Don vas
cuando empieza la guerra cuando empieza
la guerra el año pasado que venía como
un conflicto de baja intensidad hasta
ese momento el año pasado cuando empieza
la guerra estaban del orden de 8-9
víctimas en un conflicto de baja
intensidad de manera que no había ningún
motivo real para atacar a la población
civil hacerlo de una manera
indiscriminada contra blanco civiles con
esos drones que supuestamente le envió
Irán para bombardear blancos civiles es
un retroceso lamentable que va a poner
en serios en serios problemas anotan
porque Cuáles son los límites sobre los
cuales yo permanezco impávido como
testigo mando armas y armas y armas y
les doy plata como han hecho los gringos
y los propios euro y demás y que me
quedo quieto Cuando veo que están
masacrando población civil indefensa ese
es un tema muy complejo claro es
complejo Jesús Pero qué podría ser
digamos la otan y la Unión Europea para
seguir ayudando Ucrania pero para no
meterse digamos directamente en este
conflicto para No pues enfrentar estos
dos bloques estas grandes potencias
hablo de Rusia y y occidente no de
frente
bueno es que yo creo que hay una
situación particular de la que todo el
mundo está pendiente y son las
elecciones en Estados Unidos como bien
recordaban acá y yo creo que toda
intervención o toda apoyo a Ucrania o a
celenski en este momento está en pausa
estamos digamos en un momento en el que
la guerra ha perdido digamos el interés
por parte de occidente más sobre todo
por No necesariamente porque no importe
sino porque como vemos en Inglaterra
estamos viendo en Estados Unidos estamos
viendo en Europa todos los países tienen
sus propias problemas sus propias
inquietudes y De cierto modo digamos
estar pendiente de un conflicto que de
alguna forma pues es lejano para las
potencias es complicado y por un lado
Pues
pienso que una una implicación por parte
de la otana selensky de manera directa
en un momento en el que Putin está
redoblando la ofensiva y en un momento
en el que la inestabilidad política es
complicada en Europa pues es un poco
siento la otan está en un en un momento
de esperar y mirar cómo sigue el
avanzada de Putin pero como comentaba
Carlos Carlos creo que ahí hay hay poca
esperanza de que este conflicto pues
siga
va a seguir en el tiempo lastimosamente
pareciera que esto no va a ser una
cuestión de uno dos tres años sino que
puedes alargarse por mucho tiempo como
pues ya ha pasado en el pasado no
también la en la época de la unión
soviética ellos entraron Afganistán con
un plan de dos tres años y fueron casi
diez de ocupación entonces
pues esa es la el análisis que puedo
entregar vamos entonces con nuestro
último tema de la semana en nuestra
región de América Latina y el Caribe el
gobierno peruano celebró la resolución
aprobada por la Organización de Estados
Americanos oea para enviar una
delegación al país y analizar su crisis
política que confía podrá superarse con
la carta democrática Interamericana cuya
aplicación la solicitó el presidente
Pedro Castillo sin embargo el presidente
del congreso del conservador José
Williams Indicó que sea cual sea la
decisión que tome el organismo Regional
de ninguna manera va a afectar los
procesos que siguen en marcha en el
parlamento del Ministerio Público y el
poder judicial veamos Entonces como el
presidente Pedro Castillo solicitó a la
oea la aplicación de la carta
democrática Interamericana es así que mi
gobierno ha solicitado ante la oea la
activación y la aplicación de la carta
democrática Interamericana para iniciar
un proceso de consultas con todas las
fuerzas políticas los poderes del estado
y las fuerzas sociales para encontrar
con los buenos oficios de la comunidad
internacional un camino que impida una
grave alteración del orden democrático
en el Perú
Jesús o vuelvo contigo analicemos
entonces lo que está ocurriendo en Perú
también Pues otro escenario digamos otro
capítulo inestabilidad política en ese
país
no Bueno yo creo que como dice eso
esto que está pasando en Perú es
pareciera un deja uno o sea este es creo
que ya el cuarto presidente en cinco
años es una cuestión de verdad dramática
y yo creo que tiene que ver precisamente
con una crisis política interna
realmente digamos la representatividad
de la del del voto se está viendo
truncada también por la por la los
intereses de la clase política que De
cierto modo pues no permiten que ningún
presidente termine de gobernar hace
muchos años pero uno termina un un
presidente su gobierno y siento que De
cierto modo Esto está relacionado con
esa inestabilidad política y pues esto
es una nueva prueba como lo han dicho
digamos
distintos analistas este mecanismo de la
fiscalía en contra del presidente
Castillo es algo inédito pero en Perú
Pues creo que ya estamos cansados de
leer noticias sobre medidas inéditas a
vizcarra le pasó a kuczynski le pasó a
ollantando entonces De cierto modo es
algo que los peruanos están
acostumbrados y siento que ya mal
acostumbrados es decir tomado pareciera
que cada dos años Estamos cambiando de
presidente en Perú y es como si no pasar
absolutamente nada Cómo afecta esto
Carlos la democracia de Perú te lo voy a
resumir porque estamos apretados de
tiempo y Permíteme Yo leo los puntos que
he sacado adelante
estamos en un clásico esquema de lo que
se llama una democracia imperfecta
porque las instituciones peruanas están
débiles los liderazgos políticos no
recaen en los partidos sino en líderes
personal en personas con mucho
carácter y prototipo de caudillos los
partidos políticos son aparatos
solamente instrumentales durante las
elecciones han perdido legitimidad
social están desconectados de las
agencias ciudadanas no gestionan la
solución de conflictos Y eso es muy
grave en términos de gobernabilidad por
eso allá se está empezando a poner de
moda una frase que a mí me parece muy
simpática pero muy dramática es cada uno
no necesita un programa de gobierno sino
una estrategia de defensa para saber
cuánto tiempo lo van a dejar gobernar
los opositores políticos además la
oposición que ha estado haciendo sobre
todo el fujimorismo el presentado en
keiko y sus aliados es una oposición
irresponsable y reflexiva
que no mide las consecuencias de
oponerse irracionalmente a cualquier
decisión que venga de cualquiera que sea
Castillo o cualesquiera otro que haya
estado en el poder y además la sociedad
peruana que ha tenido momentos de
movilización importante no tiene hoy una
capacidad suficiente para convocar una
fuerza que sea capaz de ponerle un
contrapeso a las decisiones que se toman
en el congreso y que se toman en el
legislativo Stefano su opinión sobre
Perú un chicharrón como periodista
internacional es muy difícil tratar de
resumirlo y explicarlo a la comunidad
extranjera gente que no conoce muy bien
América Latina nada o sea tanto Jesús
como Carlos hablaron ya y conocen el
tema muchísimo más que yo Hay un
problema de representatividad
democrática eso no quiere decir que no
haya democracia en Perú hay una
democracia imperfecta que no está
funcionando por una responsabilidad
colectiva la tentación es hacer una lo
que se dice en la tiene una tabula raza
o sea una hoja blanca y empezar todo de
nuevo Y eso en particular en América
Latina puede a veces ser muy peligroso
entonces una situación que hay que
analizar de cerca y Y tratar de
resumirla bien para para gente que no no
siga el tema muy bien claro 30 segundos
empiezo contigo Stefano qué podemos
esperar la semana aquí en el mundo qué
podemos esperar ojalá Una un nuevo
gobierno en Inglaterra hablando de esto
Ojalá una una intención por parte de los
varios gobiernos internacionales ponerse
de acuerdo a resolver el tema energético
inflacionario que que es tan importante
que está afectando todo el mundo
realmente Carlos yo quisiera que la
semana entrante nos ocupemos en serio de
lo que está pasando en México el
militarismo aupado por Andrés Manuel
López Obrador traicionando a su propio
electorado es un proceso político
institucional muy grave y la comunidad
internacional especialmente la comunidad
América Latina y los propios Estados
Unidos
están pasando de acache frente a ese
tema es muy peligroso esa deriva
autoritaria que tiene un tinte
absolutamente militarista en una
democracia tan importante como la
mexicana Jesús a qué le ponemos la lupa
a la semana que viene en el mundo
una semana decisiva en Brasil se viene
una elección va a ser trascendental en
América Latina y esta semana va a ser
decisiva para para tanto bolsonaro como
para Lula y para los brasileños De
cierto modo para elegir al próximo
presidente entonces creo que ese es el
tema también que se le puede prestar
atención
Así es bueno tenemos entonces una semana
que viene también cargada de información
vamos a tener Ojalá un nuevo Primer
Ministro en Reino Unido tendríamos
también un nuevo presidente en Brasil lo
que está pasando en México que ojalá
pues también le pongamos la lupa a eso Y
por supuesto el tema internacional sin
duda desde el mes de febrero la guerra
en Ucrania yo les Quiero agradecer Ya se
nos acaba el tiempo por estar con
nosotros en nuestro programa una semana
en el mundo de Francia 24 Jesús Gracias
por estar con nosotros Jesús Meza
periodista de asuntos internacionales
también Carlos chica Carlos periodista
de asuntos internacionales y director
del post del podcast el mundo en rayos x
de la Radio Nacional de Colombia y
Stefano también Stefano Pozuelo no
periodista internacional en medios como
CNN bbc y otros medios de comunicación
Gracias ha sido un gusto haber
conversado entonces con ustedes todo lo
que va a pasar está lo que pasó esta
semana es lo que vamos a ver la semana
que viene en el mundo ustedes también
gracias por acompañar continúen con
nosotros aquí en Francia 24
[Música]